and put the number five on it that's why
i always put up the number five in all
my photos
because that's a head nod to my mother
because
[Applause]
just
really you know when i talk about
accountability and i blame myself for
everything
you know
my father
um
was such an aggressively combative
communicator
that
and also like that young man is very
good at truth and values it very much my
mother and i
we like to be a little bit more
clever
and keep it inside and
my father
was
very passionate that i just would tell
him
the problem was
anytime you told my father anything
the reaction was overly aggressive
so it started to train me subconsciously
to not you know go there
um
i am super happy
that my first
career was with my dad
and i'm incredibly happy that my next
career was with my brother
but if i'm being naked
i could have done a better job in
communicating to them
because i was the driving force of the
businesses
my brother is remarkable he was always
weary of it because he saw what happened
with my dad
so he was doing his part he was pushing
and prodding me and gave me openings my
father gave me no opening
to tell him my feelings my brother gave
me openings
and i wouldn't take him
because i didn't want to hurt his
feelings
and tell him that i felt that i was
contributing more even when he was
acknowledging it
so financially
in my
first
40 [ __ ] two years of my life i'm 46
between building my father's business
and building vayner
you know i really put myself in a
curious spot by not being candarous
where i created resentment and this goes
back to the candor
and
and
the reality is is i believe in what i
say on stage here
that wasn't their fault that was my
fault and so it's it's challenging for
me to
you know
be in a place where
i have all this good
and have these great relationships i'm
incredibly close with my father and
brother
but yet to this day notice the number i
gave myself on stage i'm still a five
it's unbelievably ingrained to me
not to tell people
what's hurting me because i feel that i
can absorb it and i'm so emotionally
strong that i can make it good in the
end it just doesn't always work out that
way
i have so many questions and so many
topics i would love to talk to you about
but time is very limited
so
i want to come to the point
you're such a successful man you're
talking a lot about
um living your passion you're talking
about your success you're talking about
um you're living a fulfilled life so
well self-reflection um what are your
rituals what are the things you do in
daily life to
live that fulfilled life to have that
success are there any routines are there
any special things you really practice
in life or is it only
the number one thing
that i'm completely convinced would work
for everyone the only thing that i'm
convinced would work for everyone it's
hard back to everything we've been
talking about because it doesn't come
natural to most people
but it is
the ritual
is
practicing gratitude every morning
so i don't meditate or pray per se
but there's not a morning that i wake up
in the world
where when i wake up
including the overnight flight
where i don't look at my phone
immediately you know a lot of people
like to wait to look at their phone
which i love you know remember when i
said and not or
one of the biggest reasons the world has
conflict
is people keep telling people what they
should do
right like i'm very happy that
meditation works for you it may not work
for someone else you can recommend all
i'm doing up here and saying hey think
about this
but i don't judge anybody when they
don't do what i do or what i hope they
do i want it for them
but for me
every morning i grab my phone right away
and if nothing horrible happened
and i let this be very clear nobody died
of the 10 people i love the most
if nothing horrible happened
i am actually incapable
of being upset during the day
i could be frustrated
i could be perplexed
i could be
for a second upset
but
i just don't know how to be upset about
anything
other than someone you love dying
i just don't think you should
let me tell you why
i have something very interesting to
tell you
when you die
you'll be dead for a very long time
are you sure
i'd love listen if this whole thing
about
souls go into like i would love to come
back
as a little danish girl
um
but
yes
when you die
you will be dead
for a long time
also i don't know if you know this
you were not born
for a very long time
we have like
even though life is long and hopefully
everybody here lives to at least a
hundred
it's also if you take a step up very
short
the concept of not squeezing the [ __ ]
out of it
from a happiness
standpoint from a trying standpoint from
an ambitious standpoint
is ludicrous to me
and so i keep it super simple
nobody died
best
day
ever
i mean it i mean it
[Applause]
to the negative people in my life
there's been some of my friends and
family that are negative that there's
two times in my life where i actually
said this i got so frustrated to a
family member so frustrated so upset
i literally told them because they were
[ __ ]
so upset about the dumbest [ __ ] in the
world
i literally told them that i wished
something atrocious happened to them the
next day
just for perspective
we just lack perspective
like we complain about ludicrous things
and so
gratitude
cool
um
behind the stage i met laura zeiler and
la rosale is a very famous life coach
here in germany you know her and we
talked about you i know that she's also
following you and she said please ask
him one question she follows you for
quite a while for many years and she
sees a development in your life
and she wants to get the answer if it's
only a gut feeling or if it's true that
you really changed over the years and
you would like to know what spiritual
what means spirituality to you and also
for your business
sorry
that was much louder than i expected
wow um
that was awesome um
you do something new every day
um
i a lot of people have reached out to me
in the last five years on this
for people that follow me
a lot of people know i'm obsessed with
context
i'm obsessed with context it's why i'm a
very good marketer
making videos on tiktok is different
than making videos on linkedin
the way i talk to a 22 year old in
germany is different than the way i'm
going to talk to a 45 year old
in afghanistan
context is everything to me i'm
religious about context which is why i
think i'm one of the most successful
content producers in the world it's why
i think vaynermedia is one of the most
successful content producers in
advertising
when people like gary i've noticed a big
change in you i remind them
that my message
is pretty consistent it's just
contextual
if you read crush it
my first book will put me on the map
i talk about making forty eight thousand
dollars a year and loving life that if
you were
ecstatic with your life and you're
making forty eight thousand dollars a
year you can stop reading this book
because this book is for people that are
unhappy
and are looking for ways to get out of
the job that's making them unhappy this
youtube and twitter thing and facebook
thing is going to be big
unlike our grandparents you can do this
after hours while you're at home with
your kids this is a big opportunity
most people saw the young
rah-rah-rah-rah
i
wrote that book during an economic
crisis
for example
if we
go into a
real
deep global recession
my content is going to change
dramatically
because what's going to be needed in
that moment is to remind everybody that
hard work is part of the equation gary
are you a spiritual person am i a
spiritual person i just said i believed
in [ __ ] ghosts
i
i would tell you
that
i'm a
extremely spiritual person
because i'm completely confused by our
lack of knowledge around intuition
just that subject matter has me off the
reservation
you know i'm i'm also spiritual in the
way that i don't like to judge people's
spirituality
meaning
i for example
do not have crystals in my house
but i love
that people have crystals in their house
because it works for them
i
was born in the soviet union where
religion was banned for 70 years so for
three generations of my family religion
was not practiced so i am not
deeply religious
yet i love that religion is so important
for so many
my ultimate spirituality
is grounded in my deep deep
love
of my fellow man and woman
and
that's what i like it for
how would you define spirituality
what does it mean for you
for me spirituality is almost like a
sixth
sense
like a framework of perspective that is
grounded in
an energy that is less tangible
you know back to gray i wore gray today
if you noticed
um
i view spirituality as a as the deepest
gray
i think so many people's struggles here
in this room
are when they're trying to be too black
and white
right they're unhappy about something
and so they find somebody new on
instagram and they follow his or her
formula and they follow it to a t
for four months and it doesn't work and
they're upset
and they think it's their fault
the only fault if there is even one
is thinking that there is something that
is black and white that will fix
everything
it's just not how life is
i personally believe and i think many
others as well that visions and to work
on your own visions to have a vision to
have a clear north star in life and
following
this north star this vision really
creates energy and power in life i know
that you believe in that as well and uh
you follow
an amazing vision you want to buy the
jets that's that's my fake vision
that's the one that i told everybody to
distract them from what i'm trying to
actually do oh you
i mean
i am
very
remember selfish and selfless
my selfish
vision
is actually very selfless
but it's only to two people
me and my mother
my goal of buying the new york jets i've
never said this publicly in my life
i've said that my goal of buying the
jets is misunderstood publicly a lot and
that my
journey to try to buy the jets is my
great love and it is
but i decided i wanted to buy the jets
as a very young child
when i was
seven my
we moved to a new town and there was a
lot of boys that were playing american
football and they were jet fans and
that's how i became a chat fan and they
all had a jets jersey right
i wanted one i asked my mother for one
we were very poor
we didn't buy that kind of [ __ ]
money was for food
and
the shelter even our clothes were liquor
t-shirts that my dad got from the store
we barely even bought clothes
we definitely didn't go on vacation we
never ate out
my mom when i was sleeping for the next
three weeks knitted me
a jets jersey
and put the number five on it that's why
i always put up the number five in all
my photos
because that's a head nod to my mother
because
[Music]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
because without a shadow you know
my mother lost her mom when she was five
my mom's dna
is
predominantly what's inside of me
luckily
i took the best stuff from my dad
and so the mix has been very formidable
i have such a gift of communication
but
at this point in my life and pretty much
from the beginning i sit on stages like
this
[Music]
because
all i want to do for the world
is what my mom did for me
this entire keynote that i just gave
[Applause]
this entire keynote that i just gave
is everything that my mom instilled in
me
and
i addressed as i mature and get older
the things that my mom and i share as a
weakness because i'm trying to do a
well-rounded thing
so
my goal in life
my north star
in real life
is two things
selfishly i want to buy the new york
jets
but i want to buy the new york jets
because what i do
i want to put in front of the stadium
because i still have it
the sweater that my mom knitted for me
[Music]
and i wanted to say
from not being able to afford a jersey
to buying the entire [ __ ] team
[Applause]
that's what i want to do selfishly
[Applause]
more importantly
more importantly
what i want to accomplish what my north
star is selflessly
is
there's so many people that want to be
successful in life
i think success
is inner peace i really do
however
i am also a purebred
100
entrepreneur
i love if
if you say i mean i'm looking at andrew
dustin was with me if you saw what
dustin saw that
on thursday it was announced that v
friends my intellectual property raised
50 million dollars from andreessen
horowitz the most important venture
capitalist in the world to build this
thing that is a very big business
accomplishment
what was i doing
while that announcement was hitting the
world i was standing behind a table
selling pieces of cardboard for ten
dollars a piece
and haggling with people who said i'll
give you eight and i said but i need
nine
i love the process of being an
entrepreneur i love being an
entrepreneur i love the game of making
money i don't need the money to fill my
insecurities my mom took care of that i
need it because i'm keeping score and
it's fun and it's a game
but i know
hundreds of millions of people
will look up to me
in the course of my life i know this to
be true
what my north star is
is to teach the world
that you can be an alpha
an alpha
a [ __ ] killer
in business
win
win and you can do it
by being an extremely
nice person
i believe
i believe
i believe
that that is something the world does
not believe right now
i believe the world thinks that you have
to have sharp elbows
that you have to crush some people's
souls that you have to hurt people that
you have to stand on people's backs to
get to the top of the mountain
my friends this is the biggest non-truth
in the world
there are two ways
there are two ways to build the biggest
building in town
one
and it is very common right now and it
is definitely the way politics works and
it is the way often times religion and
school and many other things are
packaged
civil service is beautiful
politics doing what i'm about to tell
you is atrocious
education
is beautiful
school systems doing what i'm about to
tell you is atrocious
religion
is beautiful
religious leaders
doing what i'm about to tell you is
atrocious
and here is the story
there are two ways to build the biggest
thing
one
by tearing down
everybody else's building
that's what all of those things are
doing
or two what i am in the process of doing
as an entrepreneur
by just
being talented enough
to build the [ __ ] biggest building
[Applause]
[Music]
you